le cinéma dont c'est la fête depuis
quelques minutes et pour dix jours à
cannes qu'attendez-vous international de
la pellicule de la pellicule part donc
pour la 32e fois la cuvée 79 promet
d'être une année particulièrement
brillante envoyé spécial d'antenne 2 sur
la côte d'azur france roche que nous
devrions rejoindre novell bacall et
karen black sont venus d'amérique monica
vitti d'italie il montant et jean claude
brialy de paris pour inaugurer ce
dernier festival qui est un festival de
champion en effet on n'a jamais vu
autant de grands noms en même temps les
italiens ont envoyé un quart tête de
leur grand grand grand metteur en scène
sellini en tête
francesco rosi dino risi et comencini
l'amérique nous envoie john huston
martin ritt francis ford coppola et
woody allen
le hongrois miklos jancso le polonais
wajda les allemands schlöndorff et
herzog entreront en compétition et
remettront leur titre en jeu
on dirait qu'ils se sont tous concertés
pour choisir leur sujet en effet l'amour
est vraiment en baisse on ne verra que
des films sociaux ou politiques
les dangers de la pollution atomique le
terrorisme le nazisme l'émancipation
féminine le syndicalisme la résistance
et puis toutes sortes de guerre y
compris celle du vietnam
et ce soir dans le film de miklos jancso
un phénomène qui il y a dix ans
paraissait une amusette et qui
maintenant a énormément influencé notre
monde
le phénomène hippie ce film ses airs
tirés de l'opérette de la comédie
musicale de rani et raddho qui va
chanter et danser sur l'écran du palais
mais les hippies sont aussi un phénomène
socio politique pour moi l'esprit le
plus important c'est le désir de jeunes
gens de
de protéger la liberté d'être soi même
peut faire ce que vous voulez faire
chaque pas apporte cette mouvement d'al
les années 60 elle haïti et j'ai
concentré dans l'histoire que que les
relations les sentiments sont les
sentiments qui qui ne sont eux qui n'ont
pas sont pas morts avec les années 60 ce
qui sera pas dans le film c'est que vous
avez à la fois montrer ce que le
mouvement hippie ce que le lait flahaut
pipe de 68 avait de nouveau de
révolutionnaire et en même temps ce qui
dans le mouvement hippie dure encore
aujourd'hui bon écoutez je croque dans
le mouvement des pires a apporté des
choses vraiment bon bon bon parce que
sinon les pokémon est écouté vous êtes
habillé presque comme un mendiant
américain autres collaborateurs les
cheveux longs les blue jeans et tout ça
va casser des barrières casser des barea
qui était vraiment vraiment trop
conservative pour pour le jeune homme
aujourd'hui pour tout le monde
dans votre film on est un peu hanté par
l'idée du départ au vietnam ou de la
guerre c'est toujours le sujet qui est
difficile à digérer
par exemple meilleur film sur la
première guerre mondiale de fermer le
centre en dhr c'est 38 la grande
illusion de renoir un temps après oui ça
fait pas 20 ans que la guerre du vietnam
est finie oui mais tout va plus vite
à ta partie
free
à
obama
takara
tha
le beau jeu
m
r de milos forman